(crowd cheering and clapping)
- Welcome back!
Have you met Sam before?
- No, but I've seen Sam around.
(crowd and Kelly laughing)
- Oh yeah.
- Let me get adjusted on this sofa Sam,
I'm trying to be cute.
- She's like,
I'm still trying to adjust.
- It's difficult,
you look great.
- Oh.
- I know I have to put
several pillows, I have like four pillows,
- You want some of these?
- Yeah, I do.
- There ya go Pat.
- 'cause I have no legs.
- Let me help you here Pat.
- Thank you, thank you.
- See there you go.
- I know your mama raised you right.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Yeah, well, I dunno, she
forced him into the cold ocean.
- [Ms. Pat] Oh.
(Kelly laughs)
- Wait, he was talking
about vacations earlier.
Do you, were y'all big on
vacations when you were younger?
- No, we was poor, but
I'm big on vacation now.
- Yeah, me too!
- So I get all of my
friends together, Kelly,
and I make 'em go to Disney, VIP.
(audience cheering)
- I love, to Disneyland, okay.
- Which is very expensive,
but we put it on layaway
for like a year and a half.
(audience laughing)
- And now I was poor,
I know what layaway is.
Do you know what layaway is?
- Yeah, what is a layaway?
- Well, it's when you can't afford it-
- No, let me tell him
- Okay, okay.
- It's a poor people MasterCard.
(all laugh)
That's exactly what it is.
- It's like, I can't afford it now,
but if you'll hold it
here, I'm gonna pay on it
until I-
- Oh, I'm good for it.
just lay it away for me until
I can actually pay it off.
- So on credit, right?
- Yeah, well, it's kind of different
than just putting an credit card.
- It don't affect your credit score.
- Yeah.
- But if you don't pick up your layaway,
you can lose your item and your money.
- Yeah, you can only lay it away
for a certain amount of time in the store.
- Well, in the store in 90 days.
Disney, until you your trip
is coming up, like two months.
- You know a lot about
Disney airway, right?
- Well, I always wanted
to go to Disney as a kid.
And when I was able to go
my friends can't afford
what I afford, some of them,
so I just do the same thing they doin'.
And it'd be like last
year, it was like 40 of us.
(crowd cheers quietly)
- I love Disney world.
Did you ride, have you been
on the new Avatar ride?
- Kelly, I'm too big for
everything, but I- (chuckles)
- No, you're not.
- But, but-
- You have your own like bike or dragon,
whatever it is.
- You know,
if I do it, you gonna be see
me, one of those black women,
when they wigs flyin' on the other.
(all laugh)
So I'm not gonna do that to my wig.
- Oh my God, so you're not into rides.
- No, I'm not into rides.
- So, wait, what the heck
do you do a Disney world?
- I watch everybody else have fun.
- Oh my God, I love you.
- Oh.
(crowd sighs empathetically)
That's kind.
- I dream through my kids.
I was like, go on, I could never do that.
- Wow, that's amazing.
- Oh my God,
you're such a nice mom.
I'm like, no, you're
sitting out, I wanna ride.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
- Yeah.
- I love that.
So I heard that you also
moved back to Atlanta, right?
- I just moved back to Atlanta.
- Yeah.
- I bought a couple acreage,
a couple acres, out in the
country part of Atlanta.
- I love that, space.
- And I have
12 little white neighbors,
and let me tell you somethin',
(all laughing)
- 12 little white neighbors?
- I have to tell you this story, so,
(Kelly squeals)
they Googled me
and I thought they was
gonna say, I'm a comedian.
And I called the old owner,
he called me one day, he's like,
"Patricia, we know who you are."
And I'm like uh-oh,
they done seem my dirty comedy on Netflix.
And I was like, okay.
He's like, "we Googled you,
"and we so happy to have
you in the neighborhood,
"and we all know that you're
Oprah Winfrey's sister."
(audience cackles)
- We wait what?
- We both have the same
name, Patricia Lee.
And they think I'm Oprah's sister,
and I'm trying to tell them
I'm not Oprah's sister.
My sister smoke crack.
That is-
(audience and Kelly laughing)
- Wow.
(Kelly continues laughing)
And I can't convince these 12 white people
I'm not Oprah's sister, I'm like, no,
I wish I was Oprah's sister.
- Why, why,
- Go for it.
- Lean in!
- Go with it, yeah.
- I would lean into that.
Yes I am.
- I don't-
- So every time I go to look at my house,
cause I'm remodeling, I
got cookies and cakes and
items left outside the door,
- Yeah.
and I was like
- And you be like,
I'll tell her, It's one
of my favorite things.
(all laughing)
It's like,
I would totally lean into that.
(audience clapping)
- Right.
- Don't make me use the senior citizens.
(Kelly laughing)
Cause I be wanna use 'em, but
they some sweet neighbors.
- Oh that's so funny though.
So wait, tell us what's going on
with the "Ms. Pat Show."
- Second season.
(audience cheering)
- Second season, yes.
- I'm very, it's gonna be so,
if you think the first
season was something,
the second season is out of this world.
- Oh I love it.
- We did some really deep
episodes and one of them was,
it was about black hair and black women,
about black hair and black women
where I had to really go deep Kelly,
and you know, I'm a comedian
so I'm not an actress or actor.
- Oh.
(Sam and audience chuckles)
So it took me there,
and I was shedding tears
and so many feelings was rolling up and
it's gonna be a great season.
We talking about a lot of deep
things and issues that
going on in the world.
- Do you like going that deep or does it
make you uncomfortable?
- It makes me, it used
to make me uncomfortable
but I'm learning to accept it,
because it's all about my life.
- Yeah, I love being uncomfortable.
I love leaning in and then it pushes you
and then you figure
something out about yourself.
- I feel like
she's an actress, right?
- I've gone to way
too much therapy.
- It sounds like
you are an actress.
- I'm a comedian.
(audience laughing)
- No, but I think that most,
think about comedians though.
There are a lot of great comedian,
like Robin Williams, there's
a lot of great comedians,
Eddie Murphy, a lot of
comedians are great actors.
- Yeah, but you know I-
- Yeah.
- Acting is nothing I ever wanted to do.
I just wanted to be a comedian
and I was pushed into this
and I'm like, okay, this not bad.
You know, it pays the bills.
Yeah, you're good at
it though, that's why-
They don't just keep handing out seasons
to people that are bad at it.
(laughing)
It's like yeah.
- Oh, you ain't watched TV lately.
(laughing and audience cheering)
(Kelly clapping)
I can say that, 'cuz I don't
have any Hollywood friends yet.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God.